you can't help but feel resentful
on the 22nd of may 2017 a bombing at the
manchester arena
killed 22 people
salman abadi blew himself up after an
ariana grande concert
in the worst terrorist attack in the uk
since 7-7
i think everybody has a right to take a
sharp intake of breath
and think oh my goodness so much went
wrong
a public inquiry into the bombing has
heard evidence of
unacceptable and unjustified security
failures
this is a forensic look at the missed
opportunities
to stop the manchester bomber
british transport police officer jessica
buller and pcso mark
renshaw are on duty at the city room the
foyer
of the manchester arena at 7 20
the pair leave the city room to take a
meal break they should be no longer
than an hour but they are gone for more
than
two hours at 8 48 two other community
support officers
pcso's brown and maury also take a break
cctv shows them passing salman obadi
in victoria station adjacent to the
arena
he's carrying a heavy rucksack cctv was
picking up a baby
on cameras across the city looking
suspicious you know
with his rooks hours before at 8 51
he enters the city room there are now no
police officers in the foyer
despite instructions from a british
transport police sergeant
that the area should be patrolled at all
times
i think a lot of people just couldn't
hack it and
a lot of me can understand that but he
just feels like a massive failure
what would be the expectation of the
members of the public who
went to that event i think everybody has
a right to expect to be safe and secure
but very clearly there weren't this is
the moment
that a baby is spotted by the site's
security team
security guard mohamed agar sees him
carrying his rucksack
as he crosses the foyer obeidi then
makes his way up this set of stairs
and sits down at the top he stays here
for 20 minutes
out of view it's a cctv black spot
at 9 10 salmon abedi leaves the city
room
carrying his rucksack he returns to the
metro link
where he sits down on the platform for
16 minutes
at 9 29 he makes his way back to the
manchester arena concourse
following the same route while in the
lift
he appears to be adjusting some wiring
below his jacket
at 9 33 he re-enters the venue
and makes his way back to the mezzanine
area which is not covered by cctv
he stays here for just under an hour
at 9 36 pc buller and pcso renshaw
resumed their patrol of the venue
and make their way back to the foyer
more than
two hours after they left for a meal
break
very clearly there were challenges
around
not working or gaps in infrastructure
there were gaps of understanding over
who was responsible for what parts of
the security operation
that existed and there appears to have
been failings by individuals
operating within that security system
it's now
10 15 christopher wilde has been waiting
for his 14 year old daughter
who's at the concert he approaches
muhammad aga
saying he's worried about a suspicious
person with a backpack
mr wilde has already spoken to salman
abadi
who told him he was waiting for someone
the security guard
tells mr wilde he'll report his concerns
as soon as possible
at 10 23 muhammad aga speaks to a
colleague
kyle lawler who's entered the city room
and explains the situation
mr lawler tries to radio in but can't
get through to the control room
to report the suspicious man it's the
you know unwillingness to check it out i
mean
a man alone walking in with a rucksack
to a large packed
you know place it's it's going to raise
alarm bells
it's and yet when they're raised
you know everything's done it's it's
worrying
over the next few minutes mohamed agar
and kyle lawler
have two more conversations about salman
abadi
mr lawler says he had a bad feeling
about him
but there was nothing to really justify
that feeling he also says
he was scared of being wrong and branded
a racist
he attempts to report the situation on
his radio several times
but can't make contact one of the things
that frustrated me across that period in
2017 was we'd seen this rolling wave of
terrorist attacks coming at us from
europe
and we've been putting out a strong
strong message to people like be alert
be aware
you know don't be embarrassed about
reporting things go with your senses
and of course what it appears is that
people heard that message
and they responded and they reported
seeing this guy out of place
in the proximity of the arena and nobody
was responsibility
for dealing with that seem to do
anything at 10
26 he gives up trying and takes up his
position
outside the city room because the show
is ending
at 10 30 concert goers are streaming out
of the arena
salman abadi leaves his hiding place and
walks across the foyer
he is seen on his phone he is smiling
at 10 31 he detonates his bomb
killing 22 people
of the four british transport police
officers on duty at the city room
none are in the foyer they're all in
victoria station
at the time of the blast the main
person we should blame is the bomber
no one in the government really wanted
this to happen no one in the
police ambulance fire none of them
wanted this to happen
they messed up they made human errors
they made massive errors
but the end of the day they didn't pull
the trigger he did
there were missed opportunities
unambiguously
to address
confront approach deal with the
terrorist
what i couldn't be certain of is what
would have been the outcome from doing
that
we just need to learn we need to be
hold those who are accountable
accountable
and we just need to make sure we're
better prepared should it ever happen
again i hope not
i think that is the best revenge any of
us can ever take just carry on
you